[Music]
in the sunshine in Northwest Wales at
Raf Mona just up the road
from the temperature got to 21 cius at
70 in
Fahrenheit
is that a real place I'm honestly not
sure but this is a real show and I'm a
real host Named Dave ruin you are
watching the Ruben report and we've got
another Friday Roundtable Extravaganza
for you joining me today are the
co-hosts of the chicks on the right
podcast Miriam Weaver and Amy Joe Clark
ladies welcome back to the show
hello now great to be here it's good to
be with you guys you know you've been on
a a couple times before but I want to
discuss this this nickname situation
with you guys because you don't always
go by your real name so can we explain
these nicknames Amy Joe maybe you want
to throw it out there first for me well
we started having nicknames when we we
started our our website gosh back in
2009 because we knew that we would
probably get harassed being conservative
women because you know people tend to
not like conservative women and so we
also worked in Corporate America at the
time so we're like we need to have
monikers and so picked Daisy because I
it was just easy I have a a tattoo of a
daisy on my hip and so that was just an
easy thing to pick and so I picked I
picked the name Daisy and it's stuck and
you thought that would provide some
force field from the hate somehow by
calling yourself Daisy that's
interesting completely yes we've been
completely protected from all the hate
we've never faced hate Dave ever yeah
Miriam or should I call you mock yeah
you can call me either one and actually
my name is short for Ma Rea which came
from a website that I had way back in
the day which was dedicated to mocking
pop culture celebrities politics all of
it it was called the mock do and I'd
asked my husband before we started the
site what should my name be if it's if
that's the name of the website and he
said how about the macarina and I was
like I love that and it's done and the
rest the rest is history well one of the
reasons I love you guys and it this will
be a good segue to the top of the show
in the first story is that as you just
laid out like you happen to be
conservatives but one of the things that
people seem to think about conservatives
is they're mean they're angry all of
this stuff that is just simply not true
and you guys are joyful Warriors in all
this so let's start with a less than
joyful Warrior who's on the other side
of the political aisle uh because as you
guys know it is Black History Month we
will be celebrating all month here at
the Ruben report in ways that I can't
get into on camera
um I don't know what I meant my whole
team just freaked out I don't know what
I don't know what that meant exactly
everyone calm down
um but let's jump over to the view
because it is Black History Month they
had author uh clay Kan on and uh Whoopi
was asking him about black Republicans
and these Clarence Thomas types what's
the deal with them you describ the
current ERA of black repu Republicans as
grifters and I I say that's the right
word for that what but you need to
explain to people what you mean when you
say it and what made you decide to write
this book
well first and foremost I wrote this
book because I care about this country
and I've been so saddened at the
direction that it's going in under the
Republican party it's really broke my
heart and when you think about the
original black Republicans they were the
first progressives they were the ones
that pushed Abraham Lincoln into
emancipation they were the ones that
forced him into glory after the Civil
War they are forming communities that
will help black folks and poor white
folks so I wanted to examine how did
Black Republicans go
from Frederick Douglas to Clarence
Thomas yeah how did we get here how do
we get here and so what I realize is now
the current version they are grifters
and what I mean by that is somebody who
is hustling and scheming that will say
anything and do anything to get access
to power even if it means demeaning your
own community and in many ways they
provide racial cover for the issues in
the Republican party so this book is
also about the downward spiral of racial
politics in the
GOP it really is incredible with these
people because they really only need a
mirror to figure out what they're
talking about uh before I let you guys
jump in I just want to say that that
when he mentions the black Republicans
of you know 200 years ago or 150 years
ago and calls them progressives yes
because they were progressing towards
equality which has nothing to do with
the movement towards Equity is all about
now um but Daisy why don't why don't I
start with you here I mean first off
just the the endless obsession with race
on these shows and that so many it
seemingly the reason I play these view
Clips all the time is because it's on at
the exact same time as this show it's on
right now live every day at 11:00 a.m.
and that so many seemingly middle-aged
Suburban women are are constantly being
bludgeoned with all of the wrong ideas
on this show yeah it is a long of wrong
ideas and I I'll never understand how um
Democrats liberals attach victimhood to
melanin in somebody's skin I just don't
understand that you know perhaps it's
because I I'm I'm a gen xer so I feel
like we were starting to get we were
away from that and now we're we're
hurling ourselves towards more you know
race pedaling and people are doing that
and it's it's so crazy to me how he
talks about Republicans being grifters
when it's it's such gaslighting because
that's precisely what they're doing it's
race pedaling it's they're they're the
total grift because they're People's
race yeah you do you do get all those
big endorsements by being a black or or
gay or whatever Republican that really
is how to endear yourself with
mainstream culture uh Mack um
Whoopi what is going on with this woman
everyone you know Daisy you just
mentioned Gen X it's like we're we're
all kind of roughly the same age it's
like we had put this stuff all to bed
and everyone loved people like Whoopi
you know if you would have said Whoopi
from 1998 to Whoopi now but this seems
to be what happens with so many of these
I hate to call them liberals because
they're not even liberals but you get it
yeah it's such a stunning lack of
self-awareness on their part I mean the
way that they don't hear the projection
that they're that they're doing with
these ideas you know it's it's stunning
to me to hear them say such racist
things as if you don't agree on
something in terms of a political
ideology then you're automatically only
you're pretending for a grift you can't
possibly think differently on your own
as an individual without it being tied
to a a money scheme like they are
defining themselves for us openly and
yet they don't see that we see that and
it's it's amazing also Clarence Thomas
it's like there's a lot of things you
can do when you're a high-powered legal
mind that will make you more money than
being a Supreme Court judge or if you
were to look I hate the idea of just
like listing out black conservatives but
but Larry Elder and how about this clip
from Thomas Soul debunking everything
they just said this whole notion that
this is the black family was always has
been disintegrating that that is
nonsense that his studies go up to 1925
the great bulk of black families were
intact two parent families up through
1925 and going all the way back through
the era of slavery so it is now only
within our own time that we suddenly see
this inevitable tragedy which the
welfare system says is going to rush
into sou black people have never
supported for example affirmative action
poters anything of that sort wherever
polls have been taken a black opinion on
such matters of should people be paid
equally or should there be this or that
black people have have never taken a
position that you describe so it is not
a question of what black people chose to
do it's what you you choose to put in
the mouths of black people and it's what
you choose to to project it is not what
any black people have ever said anywhere
that you can put your finger on you
choose to put into the mouth of the
pollers as far as I can see the
leadership of the black community like
most people I have never seen a poster
if you look at the leadership of the
black you think judicial activism uh
doctor has hurt blacks uh judicial
activism ISM of uh eliminating
restrictive covenants in Deeds uh um
eliminating segregation in schools uh
one man one vote literacy test you
consider those judicially active well as
regards restrictive covenants uh I can
see no evidence that they did anything
other than make some people feel good
because it was symbolic are you saying
that the variable in success or lack of
success is the culture of the particular
group yes that's exactly what I'm saying
Mack I don't even know that we need to
be on the show because we could just do
an hour of Thomas soul and that would be
just fine that's how I always feel when
we play clips of him um but but here's a
guy who you know began as a Marxist as
he's talked about for a long time you
know he's up in his in his 90s now still
still at it but purely just laying out
that it's the Democrats really whose
policies have not only destroyed the
black family but then kept so many black
people in that cycle of poverty and
everything else but I suspect they're
not that interested in that on the view
no they're not interested on The View
what a National Treasure Thomas soul is
I me god um but I you know it's
interesting to see obviously those are
older clips and and when you hear him
talk about the fact that it is these
sort of white guilt uh ridden people who
are putting this on they're projecting
it on to the black community I genuinely
don't know if that's that was true when
Thomas Soul was talking about that but
now you see so much of the the black
community buying in to all of this
victimization they're screaming for
reparations you see much more of that
and so I would love to believe that what
Thomas Soul just said there still
applies but I worry that it applies less
and less Daisy you're white according to
my paperwork here um and you're a woman
also according to my paperwork here we
did a lot of research today accurate
what can we what can we do to the to the
white gen XOM who is confused about all
of this
and that refuses to vote the right way I
mean I I really think there's there's an
opportunity to get these people now
because they these women because they
see the Border they see the problems
with education and everything else the
Republican messaging doesn't seem to be
particularly enticing I suppose oh my
God the rep yeah well the Republican
party in general I think is completely
falling apart right now as as evidenced
by like Ron McDaniel and um people who
we have in charge of Republican party
it's it we you know I think that the the
Republican party for me at least has
always been about the individual
personal
responsibility um fiscal responsibility
things like that and so when I see stuff
like when we're talking about you know
Whoopi and all this nonsense that she's
talking about grifting and and whatnot I
you know there are black people out
there who think for themselves and they
are conservative and they are you know
Republicans there are white women there
are women in general who are
conservative who are Republicans and I
think that that um goes against
narrative and so it's I think we just
need to know that we can Buck The
Narrative and you can be whatever you
want to be in this country you can do
whatever you want to do and to hell with
the narrative yeah I want I want to
stick with I want to stick with that Gen
X thing you said for a moment before
because I I've been mentioning this a a
lot on the show we had settled this I am
47 years old it was not cool to be
racist it was not cool to be homophobic
or just any of these things growing up
we've ushered it all back in do do you
guys see a way that we can really push
it back I mean I guess just keep
exposing it like we're doing here but do
you really see a way that we're going to
get rid of this or is this just kind of
the new American thing mock it's I'm
sorry go ahead I man I I used to be so
optimistic you can ask da about this I
was the one that was like everybody love
everybody and you know and now I I feel
less and less hopeful except that you do
still see signs of the pendulum swinging
so far that it has to write itself and
so I you know Daisy's really good at
finding those signs and showing them to
me and saying all hope is not lost and
so you know we we notice those in some
young people that we see today so there
are a lot of examples that kind of lead
us to believe that maybe the progressive
left has gone so crazy that now we're
going to see a correction you know what
I mean yeah I see it in my kid I mean I
have a 13-year-old Dave and I at
13-year-old girl and I see the girls and
the boys that she hangs out with and you
know I think that a lot of what what is
that is that J Alpha I don't even know
what they're called is that what they're
called I don't know are they J alha 13 I
don't know I guess I don't know but I I
see what they screw I don't know what
they called precisely but I see Jen
sorry about all that you know I don't
know Jen oh my God what is this world
yeah but I but I see these kids and I I
think that they are a little bit more
like like the Gen xers and in the way
that you know they're looking at things
and they're like some of this stuff is
so whack like we've got to have the
pendulum swing back to at least like a
little bit of normaly and just common
sense because these people are freaking
crazy you know I mean they've gone off
the deep end and they're rejecting some
of the the craziness and I and I think
that's a it's a beautiful thing speaking
of whack and crazy people who've gone
off the deep end we have a clip from CNN
for you uh Dana Bash had an interesting
uh Theory which she calls a right-wing
conspiracy theory although I think it's
kind of a left-wing conspiracy theory
that Taylor Swift is going to swing the
election enjoy have you heard the latest
conspiracy theory making the rounds
Taylor Swift Travis Kelce and the NFL
and the Democratic party are in cahoots
to get Joe Biden reelected but stay with
me prominent right-wing figures are
speculating that her relationship with
Travis Kelce is made up and that the
Super Bowl will be rigged for Kelsey and
the Kansas City Chiefs and the endgame
is Swift endorsing Biden after the big
game here are some of the messages I'm
trying not to laugh uh circulating on
social media V ramaswami I wonder who's
going to win the Super bowl next month
podcast host Mike crispy the NFL is
totally rigged for the Kansas City chief
Taylor Swift Mr fizer Travis Kelce Lara
lomer a self-described islamophobe who
has been embraced and promoted by Trump
they are going to use Taylor Swift as
the poster child for their pro-abortion
gov campaign right-wing media
personality Benny Johnson said Taylor
Swift is an
OP Daisy is Taylor Swift brought To Us
by the CIA in the Deep state or is she
just a pop star that young people are
into who happens to be sleeping with a
football star I am I am the I am the
person who will entertain conspiracy
theories I am that girl I am your girl
will sit down and listen and like wear
the tinfoil hat with you but I think
this is all kind of ridiculous okay like
and you can separate a relationship
between two people and think okay well
that's real and then also at the same
time simultaneously go okay the NFL may
be a little rigged you know you can
believe both are true but no I think
that they're just having a relationship
and that's that and I also think that
her music sucks I didn't to think that I
sat through three hours of that movie
with my 13-year-old and it was hell on
Earth you guys and I did it I took one
for the team but I don't listen you no I
don't think that it's a conspiracy
theory I I I don't think this has a lot
of or holds a lot of water I don't even
know what movie that is did she had a
movie too she had a movie well it's
listen in lie of of paying like I don't
know taking out a stck mortgage on my
house to take her to the concert it was
that it was Taylor Swift it was her
concert basically and it's three hours
long and I wouldn't recommend it if you
want to keep your
sanity yeah Mar the reason I wanted to
show this clip it's not like it's most
most important thing in the world but I
thought it Illustrated something
interesting about the tension between
mainstream media and online media and
everyone else calling everybody sort of
like the clip before a grifter or a
conspiracy theorist I don't know I know
most of those guys from the tweets that
they mentioned like I don't agree that
this is some Grand conspiracy but then
the way CNN covers it as if this is the
thing we better be watching out for it
it's all just making everyone
Dumber is it is this is the stupidest
thing and I feel like it makes
conservatives look really bad the more
that there's this hype about it all
being rigged I mean I I agree that it
this is just two people that happen to
be in love with each other and they're
both very very big in their careers
right now I don't think it's any more
than that I happen to enjoy the Kelsey
Brothers a lot and I'm enjoying like the
relationship I know people get tired of
seeing her and them and like the NFL is
really capitalizing on the fact that
she's bringing in a lot more fans and
they should like why wouldn't they but
the fact that this is somehow rigged and
that people are acting like oh my gosh
the end game is that she is going to
endorse Joe Biden of course she's gonna
endorse Joe
Biden right surprised by that this is as
if they need to rig right right as if
they need to rig the Super Bowl so that
that will trigger the ability to then
endorse Joe Biden right
it Chelsea brothers are confusing for
Liberal feminists though you got to
admit because those are two kind of
toxic masculine dudes that they're I
mean they H there're they're sort of
being force-fed this whole scenario and
you know that all the liberal feminists
are like I don't know what to think
about this because they're in a
relationship you've got the other one I
don't even know what his name is who's
the other one that looks like a viking
he looks like a viking
Jas yeah so that guy I mean they're very
masculine and these chicks are not used
to liking that and they're being forced
now to like it because you know Taylor
Swift is the poster girl for feminism so
it's I think it's weird like they're all
in a a state of like existential crisis
or something because of this for the
record I will take Dolly Parton every
time over Taylor Swift I just want to
put that out there um Ben Shapiro had
some uh cracked analyzation of the
Taylor Swift situation I'm putting aside
her politics um I would imagine that
Taylor Swift is pretty much your idea of
of a good role model isn't she for young
young girls in particular I mean my my
only critique of Taylor Swift is that
she's 34 and all of her songs sound like
a 17-year-old going through her first
breakup that that's my only critique is
that she's two years younger than my
wife my wife is a doctor and we have
four kids and Taylor Swift is 34 and
single and still acting like she's in
the dating pool and that that's my only
critique of Taylor Swift I my great hope
for Taylor Swift is that Travis Kelce
proposes to her she gets married to
Travis Kelce they have lots of babies
and a bunch of young feminist women
decide that actually is not the worst
idea and they get married and have a
bunch of babies and we can have the
Taylor Swift Baby Boom Ben Shapiro's
wife is a doctor I did not know that I
can't believe it you didn't know that no
I'm kidding that was a joke that was a
joke okay I was gonna say we talked
about that quite a bit wouldn't wouldn't
that what Ben said there at the end
wouldn't that be the beautiful thing
here and it's almost why you really
can't stop the truth that it doesn't
matter what she thinks politically right
now or anything else but if they
actually got married and were in a good
relationship and started having kids
wouldn't that be the ultimate force
field around the rest of the the
cultural nonsense that surrounds them
yeah I'll any and then think too if she
said something say she had kids and
decided to take a break from her career
and talk about the amazing choice of
motherhood and how it's changed her the
world would be set on fire like people
would not be able to deal be here for it
I would be or I guess I guess she could
go the Britney Spears route and wasn't
she like juggling in a hotel room in
Vegas that that didn't work out that
well but Michael nolles also on the
daily wire Ben's colleague wrote this on
Twitter and I thought I thought this is
just the right idea here regardless of
whether you care that much about Taylor
Swift or not Taylor Swift is
temperamentally conservative and the
right should cautiously stand her so
that's that's kind of the idea there
that she might as okay fine she's 34
acting like a 17-year-old but if the
shift happens with her uh the right may
want to be uh careful because she she
wields a lot of power Daisy this woman
cannot be stopped I mean I guess she I
don't know people talk about her
wielding a lot of power and you know
when it comes to voting and stuff like
that but there again I I go back to my
13-year-old I I can guarantee you that
um some of these young girls that listen
to her music and love her and their
total swifties a lot of the 20 something
that that can actually vote I would hope
and I I believe that they're not going
to I I know some people in my life who
are are older young people who are
voting age that will not vote for who
Taylor Swift is voting for you know so I
don't does she really wield that much
power does she I don't know I don't
think you want to get on her wrong side
you know it seems like she can have
things done to people uh speaking
speaking of another woman that you don't
want to get on her wrong side the big
story this week obviously in in Trump
land was that eege Carol won her
defamation lawsuit against Trump so she
won she was awarded by the jury 83.3 $3
million this is not a guilty verdict in
that he raped her it is about defamation
meaning he said mean things to her now
to me this is a little odd because
accusing somebody of rape seems like a
pretty bad thing so maybe he should be
suing her in any event uh we've got a
tweet up explaining what I just said
there jury orders Trump to pay 83.3
million in Damages for defaming eege
Carol and uh here is egene Carol after
the verdict you said you want to do
great things with this $83 million
settlement give us an idea about that
don't want to waste money well I do have
an idea I like to it's i' like to give
the money to something Donald Trump
hates if it will cause him pain for me
to give money to a certain to certain
things that's my intent well perhaps a
fund for the women who have been
sexually assaulted by Donald
Trump Mark I I I don't know what
happened truly I don't think anyone I
think there were two people who know
what either did or didn't happen and
it's Egan Carol and Donald Trump I I
don't know that anyone knows anything
beyond that again he was not convicted
of rape but there has been something
about her media tour this week where
she's on Rachel mattow hysterically
laughing saying she's going to buy her
an apartment and they can go shopping in
Europe and all the rest that feels
extremely inauthentic I do want to be
careful with my words because I don't
want her to sue
me right well right I was just going to
say that I mean I want to tread lightly
because I just want to make it clear
this is my opinion
but she is a
lunatic that seems to a
letter mean there's no getting around
like all the the videos of her that that
I mean going back to that interview that
she did with Anderson Cooper where she
was talking about how rape is so sexy I
mean the woman is unhinged and so this
judgment is Extreme obviously but I I do
think Trump you know always seems to be
his own worst enemy um and so when he
gets judge there's a judgment for $5
million uh because he defamed her the
wrong thing to do is to keep saying the
things that you just got the $5 million
judgment for and yet that's exactly what
he did so they were like sharks in the
water and they were smelling all the
blood and they were like well let's just
sue him again and then when his you know
when he walked out during closing
arguments the jury there saw that as
being disrespectful and they were like
back on some more money so there's a lot
of things that I hope I think this is a
ridiculous judgment but at the same time
I hope that Trump steps back and starts
thinking more carefully about continuing
to do the very things that always get
him into trouble yeah because he's he
becomes he started to become like Jud
Nelson in The Breakfast Club where he
was just like with the detentions you
know
where another can I have another and
he's like not even close bud so I mean
like we got to 3 million and it was just
like can you just stop just stop it and
then like we're all like Marley ringwall
going just stop just stop stop yeah so
we really want him to stop I mean even
though we do know she is you know a
couple sandwiches short of a picnic this
lady and he should be able to say all
the things right it's ridiculous that he
can't push back against something that
he clearly feels is wrong of her to say
and he tried to counter Sue that was
that was dismissed outright or he lost
that case so it's just a mess but the
amount of money my God God and the and
the star studded parties and the you
know with MSNBC people and the it's just
you're right it's disingenuous it's
gross it's all the the people that are
supporting her and and they're calling
her an icon which I mean what does that
say to women who have been brutally
raped well also just her her affect on
all of these shows if you were in fact
brutally raped by him at the what was
the Nordstrom's dressing room or
whatever it was it's like I I even 40
years later I don't think you'd be
giggling and laughing about it and
everything else You' I think you'd be
saying boy you know it was it was a
horrible thing that happened the jury
did the right thing I'm going to donate
this money to X Y and Z but the tour uh
but do you guys think that they realize
between the the judgments and the trials
and taking him off the ballots and
everything else that that is exactly the
fuel that is has uh allowed for his
resurrection here or do you think they
know it and maybe or do you think they
want it because they think he's maybe
easier to beat than some of the other
people that have since dropped
out I mean I think Democrats by and
large really really want and are pleased
that he seems to be becoming the nominee
and you know I Dave I was with you like
I was all in for disantis and was just
crushed that he got out and I to me it's
like I just look at at the country and I
think what are we doing we we threw away
the best possible leader that has
achieved all the results that he has and
we're we're going for a guy that has is
going to spend all of his campaign money
on his trials like what are we doing but
and so I I do think though if Biden is
the nominee because who knows what's
going to happen that I mean we have
theories on that yeah we're crossing our
fingers so hard that it is Biden that
Trump is up against because if it's
anybody else I don't think he has a
prayer and I say that yeah no I I get it
I think why they've pushed him so far
and and caused that Resurgence but Daisy
what are those theories that you guys
have on the Biden PR I I personally
think they're going to slip Gavin the
weasel sleazy greasy weasel Gavin in
there at the last minute like in May
they're just going to slip him in there
and it's going to be because of you know
like his he Biden's health problems
which clearly he like he has no idea
where the hell he is and so it's like he
just the guy is full on dementia he
cannot go four more years you guys I
don't know how but what do they do what
do they do about Camala cuz it's not
that you can just get rid of him and
then you still have to deal with her and
they know they can't run her so what do
you do there give her a Kush College job
somewhere maybe Harvard or promiser a
supreme court position right I mean
there's a way there's I feel I feel like
where there's a will there's a way and
the Democrats are so good at just being
awful and they've they so they'll find a
way to do it and but clearly I mean you
look at the two people they have they're
terrible terrible people and they're not
doing a great job and so but they're
never GNA admit that because you know
it's just it's right now it's well you
just don't know who bring it to you and
so that's that's the messaging right now
but I feel like at you know in the next
couple months they're going to try to
figure out a way to finagle another
candidate because there's just no way
Joe Biden can do four more years I'm
praying for Joe Biden's Health just
really really really
want he is the president he's flying the
playing at the moment that's just the
truth ladies instead of ending on
politics what do chicks on the right do
on the weekend mock you first well right
now I am scared of everything and
everyone and I want to just be at home
all the time because the world is so
crazy and it didn't used to be that way
but that is what I will be doing this
weekend is chilling out at home with my
family and for me that's I know right
it's I got to get her out of the house
more we got to get her out and for me I
we I have a a state level swimmer that
she I go to swim Meats a lot and then we
also have lots of animals here on the
ranch we have Brahman cattle and I have
lots of dogs so that's what I do fun fun
ladies it was good seeing you hopefully
the world will correct Itself by Monday
although probably
not than it was a pleasure have a great
weekend we'll have you guys back soon
and for everybody else postgame show
coming up in about 30 seconds Ruben
report. locals.com as they they say in
uh Mexico audience in Little Rock we
also saw the hottest day of the year in
nearly four years actually let's check
in with first though with chief
meteorologist Keith manahan and Keith
are we looking for any sign of possible
relief on the way no back to
[Music]
you
a